So before we get to the problem of ranking web
search results, I want to talk about one more interesting recursive
definition, the fibonacci series. And fibonacci numbers are one of
the most interesting things in mathematics. Once you know about them,
you'll see them all over the place, both in nature
and in human designs. The name comes from Leonardo da
Pisa who was also know as fibonacci. And back in
1202 he published a book called Liber Abaci. The root Abaci
is the same as the one for abacus the calculating
machine. And this translates loosely as book of calculus. This
was the book that introduced Indian mathematics to the west.
In particular it introduced what we now know as Arabic
numerals. This replace the Roman numeral system that was then
widely used. And part of what fibonacci did in the
book was show, how much easier it is to do
calculations, using numbers in the decimal systems where the place,
where the number is indicates its value. And as part
of the book introduce these problems, and showed how to
solve them using calculation. The problem that became known as
the fibonacci numbers was one of the problems in the book.
And he posed a problem like this. So at the
beginning, we have one pair of rabbits, and it takes
one month for a rabbit to produce offspring, and every
month a mature rabbit will produce a new pair of rabbits,
so at month one, we had one pair of
rabbits. At month two, well, we have the one pair
we started with. And now we have a new pair.
We have two pairs of rabbits. And now at month
three the baby rabbits aren't yet ready to produce offspring.
It takes a month for the rabbits to reach maturity.
But these two will produce new offspring each month. So
we have one new pair of baby rabbits and the
rabbits that were born in month two, well they've had
a month to get bigger. So now, they're mature rabbits.
So we had three pairs at the end of month
three. So month four we still have the three pairs of
rabbits we had, rabbits never die in this model, and
the two pairs that are mature, both of those will now
produce new rabbits. So we have two new pairs of
baby rabbits. The baby rabbits that were born in month three,
well now those are mature. So now we have
three pairs of mature rabbits, and two pairs of baby
rabbits, so we have five pairs of rabbits total. And
this keeps going, so the model assumed that rabbits never
die, that every month each pair of mature rabbits
produces a new pair of rabbit babies. And it takes
one month for a pair of rabbits that spawn, to
become mature. So in month five, the three mature pairs
of rabbits, will all produce new offspring. New offspring,
new offspring, three new offspring. And the two that
are a month old, that were born in month
four, now become mature. So this isn't a very
accurate model of how rabbits reproduce. It's good for
us, if it was an accurate model, it would
only take a few years for rabbits to control
the entire planet. But it's an interesting mathematical model.
And the model that this poses, we can write in
a more formal way. So, the number of rabbits is
the number of rabbits we had in the previous month,
since those rabbits don't want to die. So in month five,
we have the five pairs that we had in the
previous month, plus all of the rabbits that were mature, meaning,
all of the rabbits that we had, two months ago,
which was three if we're on month five while those reproduce.
So we have three new pairs of rabbits, plus
the five that we have in the previous month. And
this keeps going. So we could in month six, we're
going to have the eight rabbits that we had at the
end of month five, plus the five mature pairs,
one, two, three, four, five, will each reproduce. So we'll
have five new pairs, and that will give us 13
pairs of rabbits. So this was the model fibonacci developed.
And the question is, can you figure out, at the end
of month n, given any number n, how many rabbits will
there be? So the way we define this mathematically is a
little different from the way, fibonacci posed the question. And that's
because in modern mathematics, we usually like our series to start
with a zero. If we are thinking of modeling rabbits, well
that doesn't quite make sense to start with zero rabbits. But
if we're thinking of it as a more general series, it does.
So the way it's defined mathematically is that
we say that the fibonacci number zero, is defined
as zero. Fibonacci number one is defined as one,
and those are our two base cases. So this
is different from the other recursive definitions we've seen
in that the two base cases. Previously, all of
our definitions just had one base case. And then
we can define every other fibonacci number, but first
we'll be starting from these base cases. And so, the fibonacci number n,
where n is some whole number greater than one, is, well we
have all the rabbits in the previous month. So, that's fibonacci of n minus 1,
plus, all the new babies. And the number of new
babies is the number of rabbits we had two months
ago, those are all the mature rabbits. That gets added
to the number of rabbits we had the previous month.
So that's how we define fibonacci numbers. This defines every fibonacci number
in terms of the two base cases, and in the one recursive case.
So, your goal is to define a procedure called fibonacci.
That takes a natural number as input. So, numbers starting
from 0, any whole number 0 or higher, and outputs
the value of that fibonacci number, defined using this recursive definition.